sieben tagen ganz genau zeigt ihnen das
noch einmal ganz kurz zur erinnerung
also es gibt keinerlei überlegungen
derzeit die steuern auf sprit zu senken
nein
und jetzt hat er gibt es aber diese
überlegungen richtig
es gibt überlegungen zu entlasten ob das
jetzt da ganz welche steuer ist genau
sein wird herr weise sie können mich
jetzt erst mal fragen nochmal ich will
am ende dass wir eine ampel das hinter
verschlossenen türen schnell diskutieren
damit wir schnell mit eine entscheidung
und ein lokal wirkung heraus aber jetzt
sind wir den richtigen schritt weiter
immer öffentlich diskutiertes nichts
passiert das machen wir anders na ja
finanzminister hat öffentlich gemacht
heute in dem er weitere schritte
angekündigt hat herr stegner aber
vielleicht können sie helfen sie stellen
ja auch den ein oder anderen minister
und im übrigen auch dem bundeskanzler
vielleicht hat er ja sogar auch als
früher war finanzminister in der frage
der position ja der punkt ist der dass
es leicht ist forderungen zu erheben und
nicht zu gucken welche wirkungen das hat
uns seriös ist dass man sich auf ein
massnahmenpaket verständlich dass herr
wird auch klar gesagt das ist die
meinung der ampel insgesamt ist die
bürger entlasten müssen gerade
diejenigen mit den normalen geringen
gehältern die die viel fahren müssen und
da gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten das
zu tun was haben wir davon wir werden
einer schraube drehen und die
mineralölkonzerne zum beispiel denken
gar nicht daran das weiterzugeben
sondern erhöhen im zweifelsfall ihre
preise und dann ist es am ende plus
minus null so was darf doch nicht
rauskommen am ende und deswegen werden
wir ihnen in kürze sagen welche form der
entlassung es gibt das ist eine gibt da
sind wir uns in der ampel völlig einigen
anders als zu sparen müssen wir seriös
machen das auch funktioniert gibt nach
weniger forderungen erheben sondern man
muss das auch so umsetzen ist auch die
richtigen trifft kommt ihr richtigen
entlastet wie hast das finde ich nun
entscheiden das ist eine ganz
entscheidende frage lassen wir einmal
nachfragen ersparen bevor wir zu ihrer
finanzierung kommen und zwar das ist
wenn es darum geht die richtigen zu
treffen wie sie es sagen da meinen sie
wahrscheinlich nicht zuerst der
einsparung der heute auch für 100 euro
getankt hat oder über 100 euro wie er
gerade verraten hat geht das denn beim
spritpreis überhaupt dass man eine
schnelle wirkung also ganz schnell
entlastet das die menschen tatsächlich
eine schnelle erleichterung haben an der
tankstelle und dass das trotzdem nicht
einfach rasenmäher ist und alle
gleichermaßen entlastet sondern
tatsächlich babys brauchen da gibt es ja
verschiedene instrumente über die wir
gelernt haben ich habe schon von der
pendler angesprochen die das sind die
besonders betroffen die jedoch durch
besonders weite wege zu fahren haben und
aufs auto angewiesen aus dem ländlichen
raum ja teilweise wirklich der fall das
kann man kurzfristig nicht ändern
deswegen haben wir uns darauf
verständigt in der koalition und so ist
es mit anderen dingen auch wo man
geringverdiener gezielt entlastet auch
da haben wir sonst verschiedenes
verständigt am kern im kern geht es
darum nicht wo man was bezahlt sondern
was am monatsende noch im geldbeutel ist
und wenn es besondere belastungen durch
die kriegssituation durch diese aktion
gibt dann müssen wir die bürgerinnen und
bürger von denen wir wissen dass sie
besonders belastet sind versuchen zu
entlassen daran arbeiten wir mit
verschiedenen maßnahmen und am ende wird
es ein vernünftiges paket sein und ich
lasse sich nicht zu viel zeit weil in
der zeit muss man ja auch tanken in der
ganzen zeit und muss man die rechnung
bezahlen der krieg geht jetzt 14 tage
und jetzt ändert hat 18 entschuldigung
wir sind dabei haben das erste
entlastungspaket schon beschlossen das
zweite wird in kürze folgen damit nicht
ganz sicher dass jetzt schon auf eine
schnelle lösung kommt